hey Chris yeah it's definitely a scene
over here and you know fans are chomping
at the bit when it comes to this parade
and of making their presence known here
as they're ready to go
I mean we are hours away right we are
hours away from this parade and the
dedication is showing through this team
that was ready for a championship and
it's really interesting to talk about
just the growth that the city and this
team has had over the course of many
years there was highs there was lows
going back to their time in San Antonio
and we've talked about this team so much
just the accomplishments that they've
had they've done everything that you can
do in one single season when it comes to
this I mean you have the two-time MVP in
Asia Wilson get the most improved player
and Jackie young yet the All-Star game
MVP and Kelsey plum in the finals MVP
and Chelsea great I mean then you got
the title you got the best record in the
league all of the things that you can do
I mean a lot of people like to have
conversations about who's the greatest
team of all time we think that we have
to wait 10 20 30 years
I mean we might not have to wait long
when it comes to this and the dedication
is out here today and these this city
obviously was was so hungered for a
championship in a major Pro Sports and
they're doing it right now and and the
fans are showing out to say the least
and we still got a lot of time obviously
if if you're on Twitter you know Asia
Wilson she's made a presence known and
how the festivities will be on her end
and all of these players they are taking
it as a party in every way shape and
form and we'll be out here for every
single part of it down on the ground